The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: Today,
we continue our theme
on integer data structures.
And we're going to cover
one data structure called
fusion trees, which introduces
a bunch of cool concepts using,
you might call bit tricks,
using the word level parallelism
to do lots of great things.
To do those great things we
need to do something called
sketching, which is essentially
taking w-bit integers
and making them
less than w-bits,
but still having enough
stuff that we care about.
And then we can actually
compute those sketches
using integer multiplication
in a very clever way.
And given a bunch of
these slightly less than w
bit numbers we can
compare several
for the price of one operation
as a parallel comparison.
And then a particularly
nifty thing,
which is new this time I
haven't covered it before,
is how to compute
the leftmost 1 bit
in a w-bit integer in
constant time, all very cool.
And so we're going to
combine all these techniques
and get fusion trees.
What do fusion trees
give us in the end?
Basically, the goal is to get
log base w of n, predecessor
and successor.
So we're again talking about
the predecessor problem.
We did log of w last time with
van Emde Boas and y-fast tries.
So then with the two
of them together, we
get log w and log base w of n.
The min of those
two things is always
at most root log n, but
sometimes much better
than that.
So fusion trees are
great when w is big,
van Emde Boas was good
when w was smallish.
Like poly log n, van
Emde Boas is optimal.
Here, we're thinking
about w being closer to n,
or maybe n to the
epsilon or something.
Then we get constant time,
if it's n to the epsilon.
Anyway, the version we're
going to cover is static.
And it's linear space, and
it runs on the good old word
RAM, which you may
recall is regular C
operations on w-bit words.
w is at least log n,
so you can do random access.
And anything else?
I think that's the
version we will cover.
And that is the original
version of Fredman and Willard,
and it was invented
in 1990, which
was one year after the
cold fusion debacle.
So this may be where
this name came from.
There's other reasons it might
be called fusion trees, which
we'll get to.
Cool.
So now, there's other
versions of fusion trees
which I will not cover, but
just so you know about them.
And in some sense we
will pseudo cover them.
There's a version
for an AC0 RAM.
This is a model we
haven't talked about.
It's another version of
a trans-dichotomous RAM,
somewhere off to the
side next to word RAM.
AC0 is a circuit model.
And it's basically any constant
depth circuit of unbounded fan
in and fan out.
And so in particular
what AC0 forbids
are operations like
multiplication.
I think this used to be a
bigger deal than it is today.
I think multiplication used
to be in order of magnitude
slower than integer addition.
I checked on current
Intel architecture.
It's about 3 times
slower than an addition,
because of pipelining a
lot of things get cheaper.
But in some theoretical
sense, multiplication
is worse than a lot
of other operations,
because you need to have
a log and depth circuit.
So you can't quite get
as much parallelism
as you can with
integer addition.
If you don't know
about circuit models,
don't worry about it too much.
But AC0 means no multiplication,
sort of simpler operations.
The weird thing
about the AC0 RAM
is it lets you do weird things,
which are AC0, but are not
in C. So you could look
at the intersection of AC0
RAM and word RAM, and that
would basically be word RAM
without multiplication.
But AC0 RAM allows
other operations
as long as there's some
circuit that can compute them.
Sometimes they're
reasonable operations
like most significant set
bit is an AC0 operation.
So, you don't have to do any
work to get this operation.
So, in some sense this
makes your life easier.
In other ways it makes
your life harder,
because there is
no multiplication
and we're going to
use multiplication
to compute sketches
and other things.
So it's both better and worse.
This is by Anderson
and others a few years
after the original fusion trees.
More interesting
is that there are--
so this is a version
of fusion trees.
More interesting are the dynamic
versions of fusion trees.
So there's one that
the first version--
it's actually published later.
There's a general trick
for dynamizing static data
structures.
We actually saw one.
You may recall weight balanced
search trees was a way
to dynamize a static
data structure.
It turns out it doesn't work
so great on fusion trees.
Because the time to build a
fusion tree is polynomial.
It's not linear.
And so that's kind of annoying.
You need polynomial time
to build this thing.
So weight balance is not enough
to slow down the rebuilds.
There's another structure,
which we won't cover,
called exponential search trees.
It has this log log n overhead.
But other than that, it gives
you a nice time dynamization.
So these are updates.
There's another version
which uses hashing,
and achieves log base w
expected time for updates.
This is by Raman.
And so this gives you matching
the fusion tree query bound,
you can do inserts and deletes,
the same amount of time
if you allow expected.
And essentially the idea is to
do sketches more like hashing.
I mean, think of sketching
as just hashing down
to a smaller universe.
And in expectation
that will work well,
although it's open,
actually, whether you
can achieve this bound
with high probability.
So it's an interesting
open question.
So that's the various
versions of fusion trees.
But we're going to just
cover the static ones,
because they're
interesting enough.
Dynamic ones are not that
much harder than the regular.
So how do we achieve
log base w of n?
Well we've already seen B-trees
which achieve log base b of n.
So presumably it's
the same idea,
and indeed that's what we'll do.
What we want is a B-tree with
branching factor ideally w.
We can't quite achieve w though.
So it's going to be w to
some small constant power.
And 1/5 is the one that
I'll use in this lecture.
You can improve it or
make it worse, up to you.
But any constant
up here will do.
Because then log
base w to the 1/5
is going to be five
times log base w of n.
So we have a node.
So it has branching
factor w to the 1/5.
Then the height of
the tree, of course,
is theta log base w of n.
So that's all good.
But now what we need to
do is, doing a predecessor
search given a node, we need to
decide in constant time which
branch has our answer.
So normally in a B-tree you
would read in all these keys,
and then compare your
item to all of them,
and then decide which way to go.
Because in a B-tree we can
read all of these items
in one operation.
Now here, is that possible?
Think about it.
You've got each of these
keys is w bits long.
There's w to the 1/5 of them.
So the total number
of bits in the node
to store all those keys is w to
the 1 plus 1/5, which is a lot.
There's no way you can read all
those bits in constant time.
You can only read order
w bits in constant time.
So we can't look at them all.
Somehow, we still have to figure
out which way to go correctly
in constant time.
So this is the idea
of a fusion node.
We need to be able to store k,
which is order w to the 1/5.
Keys, I'm going to
give them some names,
x0 up to xk minus 1.
Assume that they've
been presorted.
We can preprocess and
do all those things.
I'm going to go constant time,
predecessor and successor,
and it's going to
be linear space,
and it's going to require
polynomial preprocessing.
And this is the annoying part.
If this was just
k preprocessing,
it would be easy to make
fusion trees dynamic.
But it's k to squared,
or k cubed or something,
depending on how fancy you are.
It's not known how to
do it in linear time.
So that's really our goal.
If we can implement
fusion tree nodes
and do constant time predecessor
on this small value of n
basically, when n is
only w to the 1/5.
If we can do constant
time for that,
then by plugging in B-trees
we get the log base w of n
for arbitrary values of n.
So it's really all
about a single mode
and doing that fast.
So, the rest of the
lecture will be about that.
So, I want to introduce
this idea of sketching.
And to do that
I'm going to think
about what it takes
to distinguish
this small number of keys.
High level ideas, well
we've got w to the 1/5 keys.
Each of them is w bits.
Do you really need all
w bits for each of them?
It seems a little excessive.
If there's only w to the 1/5,
you should only need about w
to the 1/5 bits of each
to distinguish them all.
So that's the intuition.
And indeed, you can
formalize that intuition
by viewing each of the keys
as a path in a binary tree.
So this represents the
bit string 01011101.
0 means left.
1 means right.
This is a transformation
we'll use a lot.
So maybe that's in your set.
Maybe this other bit
string is in your set.
Maybe this bit string--
oh, I've got to make these
the same height which
is a little challenging.
So maybe those are the three.
Suppose you just have these
three bit strings, w bit
strings in your set.
So this is a tree of height w.
Because each of the keys
has w bits, so maybe k is 3.
And those are your three keys.
OK.
The idea is, look at
the branching nodes.
Where's a color?
So, you've got a branching node
here and a branching node here.
Because there's
three leaves, there's
only going to be
two branching nodes.
So the idea is, well I really
only care about these two bits.
Or it would be enough to
think about these two bits.
OK.
Well, we'll look at this
more formally in a moment.
But by storing this bit,
I know whether the key
is over here on the left
or over here on the right.
And then by storing
this bit, I don't really
care about it for this word.
But it will distinguish
these two words.
So if you just look at the bits
that contain branching nodes
in this tri-view, then it's
enough to distinguish all
of the xi's.
So this is x0, x1, x2.
OK.
Let me formalize
that a little bit.
So we have k minus 1 branching
nodes in this height w
tree of the k keys.
Because there's
k leaves, there's
going to be k minus 1 branching
nodes, because the k leaves are
distinct.
So this means there are at most,
k minus 1 levels containing
a branching node.
It might be fewer.
Maybe it's nice to add
in another key over here
on the left.
I mean if I was lucky, there'd
be another key over here,
and then I'd be using
this bit and getting two
for the price of one.
If I'm less lucky, it
will be more like this.
So here's another x value.
And in this case, I care
about this branching node.
So I care about
another bit here.
OK.
But if I have four keys, it
will be at most three bits
corresponding to these levels.
So call these-- these
levels correspond to bits.
This is the first bit, second
bit, third bit, and so on.
This is the most
significant bit, next,
and then the least
significant is at the bottom.
So these levels correspond
to important bits.
That's the definition.
And we're going to give
these bits a name, b0, b1,
up to br minus 1.
Those are bit indices saying
which bits we care about.
And we know that r is less than
k, and k is order w to the 1/5.
So there are only w to
the 1/5 important bits
overall among these k keys.
So the idea is don't store
all w bits for all the keys.
I mean you have to store them.
But don't look at them.
Just look at these
important bits for the keys.
And then life is good.
Because there's only w
to the 1/5 bits per key.
There's only w to the 1/5 keys.
And so the total number of
important bits among all k keys
is small.
It's only w to the 2/5,
which is less than w.
So it fits in a single
word, and we can
look at this in constant time.
So that seems like a good thing.
Let me tell you what
properties this has.
Let me also define the notion
of a perfect sketch of a word.
x is going to be what
you get when you extract
bits b0 to br minus 1 from x.
So in other words, this is a bit
string, an r-bit string who's
i-th bit equals bit bi of x.
So you've got a bit
string which is x.
You say, oh, the important
ones are this one, this one,
this one, and this one.
Inside here is
either a 0 or a 1.
And there's other bits
which we don't care about,
because they're not important.
And we just compress
this to a 4-bit string.
0110.
OK.
This is sketch of x.
And to be a little bit
more explicit about how I'm
labeling things, this is b0.
This is b1, b2, and b3.
Because you number bits--
I think this is right,
we'll see later--
we're going to number bits
from the right-hand side.
This is 0-th bit, first
bit, second, third, fourth;
which is the opposite of this
picture, unfortunately, sorry.
This is a bit 0, bit 1, anyway.
This will be convenient.
So, that's perfect sketch.
For now, I'm going
to assume that we can
compute this in constant time.
This one answer is
it's an AC0 operation.
That's not so obvious,
but it's true.
So on an AC0 RAM, you can just
say, oh, this is an operation.
Right?
It's given one word.
And, well OK.
It's given these
description of bit numbers,
but those will also
fit in one word.
And then does this
bit extraction.
We're going to see a
reasonable way to do it.
But for now, take that as an
unreasonable way to do this.
So perfect sketch is
good, because it implies
the following nice property.
If you look at the
sketch of x0 that's
going to be less than the
sketch of x1, and so on,
which is going to be less
than the sketch of xk minus 1.
Sketch preserves order.
We assume that--
where do we have it?
Over here, x0 is less than
x1, is less than xk minus 1.
And because we're
keeping all the bits
where are these xi's
get distinguished,
this one it doesn't matter
whether we kept here,
it doesn't matter whether
we kept these guys.
But in particular,
we keep the bits that
have all the branching nodes.
That will preserve
the order of the xi's.
So we know that the
order of the xi's is
preserved under sketching.
The trouble is the following.
Suppose you want to do a
search, a predecessor search.
So, you're given some query q,
and you want to know where does
q fit among the xi's.
Because that will tell you
which child to visit from here.
So, OK.
You compute a sketch
of q, seems reasonable,
and move into sketch world.
And now you try to
find where sketch of q
fits among these guys.
So you can do that.
And I claim you can do
that in constant time.
It's again, an AC0 operation.
But the nice thing is the
sketches all fit in one word.
Also this single sketch fits
in one word, no big surprise
there.
So let's say you can
find where sketch of q
fits among these items
in constant time.
The trouble is were the sketch
of q fits is not necessarily
the same as where q
fits among the xi's.
Because q was not involved
in the definition of sketch.
q is an arbitrary query.
They come online, I mean
any word could be a query,
not just the xi's.
So you've set everything up
to distinguish all the xi's.
But q is going to fall off
this tree at some point.
And that kind of messes you up.
Because if q fell off here,
you don't have that bit.
You won't notice
the q fit there.
So we have to do some work.
And this is what I
call de-sketchifying.
And I like a big board.
OK, let mean draw a some more
methodical and smaller example.
I need to make it the
right number of levels.
A little bigger than my usual
tree, and I'll get my red,
actually maybe use two colors.
So here's a real example.
Now it has four keys.
And here I'm in the lucky case,
where this is an important bit.
And I get two for
the price of one.
I cared about this
branching node,
and so I only have to
door two bits in my sketch
for these four nodes.
In general, it
might be three bits.
But this will just
make the point.
So it's actually,
life is in some ways
harder in this situation.
OK.
So what are my bit strings here?
Over here I've got 0000, which
corresponds to always going
left.
And I've got 0010.
Over here I've
got 1100 and 1111.
We drew these pictures
for van Emde Boas, right?
The idea is we're
going to use some
of the similar
perspectives at least.
OK, but the important bits were
the very first, the leftmost
bit I should say.
And then two bits after
that, so these guys.
And so the sketch here
is 11, 10, 01, and 00.
And you can see this is
the minimal number of bits
I need to keep them in order.
But it does.
It works.
You can check.
This works in general.
OK.
Now comes the query.
I have a problematic
query I'd like to draw.
And it is 0101, so 0-1-0-1.
So here's my query queue.
Let me draw these as white.
Query is 0101.
1 If we take the
sketch, we get 00.
Those are the important bits.
So if I search for
the query of 00,
I will find that it
happens to match this key,
or it matches the
sketch of this key.
But that key is neither the
predecessor, nor the successor
of that query.
So this is bad news.
I find the predecessor in sketch
world, which is the red stuff,
I get the wrong answer.
In general, they could be
very far away from each other.
Here, I've got it 1
away, but that's as big
an example as I can draw.
So, how do we deal with this?
This is the de-sketchification.
So when I do this query, I
end up finding this guy, x0.
I claim that I can still use
that for something interesting.
OK, let's say we
have a sketch of xi
as the predecessor
of the sketch of q.
And so sketch of q is
sandwiched between a sketch
of xi and sketch of xi plus 1.
First of all, we're
assuming that I
can compute this
in constant time,
I can find where sketch of
q fits among these guys.
Because it just fits into words.
And for now, let's just
assume all operations
on a constant number of
words are at constant time.
We will see how to do this.
This is parallel comparison.
So you figure out
sketch of q fits here.
I want to learn something about
where q fits among the xi's.
It's obviously, these
may be the wrong answer.
But I claim I can do
something useful by looking
at the longest common
prefix of those words.
So I want to compare q, not
sketch of q but the real value
q, and either xi or xi plus 1.
And what I want is the longest.
So I look at the longest
common prefix of q and xi.
I look at longest common
prefix of q and xi plus 1.
Whichever of those
is the longest that's
my longest common prefix.
In the tree, it's the
longest common ancestor,
or lowest common ancestor.
OK.
So let's do it.
We found that sketch of
q fit between, I guess,
these two guys, the
way I've written it
with the inequalities.
It's between x0 here and x1.
So in this case, the
lowest common ancestor
of this node and q
is going to be here.
Also this node and q
happens to also be here.
So this is the lowest we can go.
And what this means
is that these guys,
they share the bit
string up to here.
We were on the blue
substructure up till here.
This was the node
where q diverged.
We followed a pointer here
along a non-blue edge.
That's where we made a mistake.
So this lets us
find, in some sense,
the first mistake, where
we fell off the tree.
So that's where we
fell off the blue tree.
That's useful information.
Because now we know, well,
we went to the right,
whereas all the actual data is
over here in the left subtree.
There is no blue
stuff in the right.
So that tells us a lot.
If we want to now find
the predecessor of q,
it's going to be whatever
is the max in this subtree.
So, I just need to be able
to find the max over here.
So this is the idea.
Now there's two cases, depending
on whether we were in the right
or in the left from that node.
So let me write
this, find the node y
where q fell off the blue tree.
So this node y, we can
think of as a bit number.
Here the leftmost
bit was still on,
but then the next bit was off.
And so we look at--
I'll call that bit y plus 1,
or maybe size of y plus 1.
If that bit equals 1,
that's the picture we have.
Then what I'm going to do
is set a new quantity e,
which is going to be--
this is a new word.
It's going to be the bit
string y, followed by a 0,
followed by lots of 1's.
Whereas our bit string q had a
1 here, and fell off the tree.
What we're instead
going to do is
identify this node, the
rightmost node in this subtree.
That's not necessarily an xi.
But it's a thing.
And then we're
going to do, again,
this search and sketch space,
but now using e instead of q.
If we do that,
what is this node?
Let's label it, 0011.
If you look at the sketch
bits, this has a sketch of 01.
So if I did a search
here, I would actually
find that this is
the answer, and that
actually is a predecessor of q.
In general, this is
going to work well.
Because essentially
some of these bits
are going to be sketch bits.
This one was not, and
we made a mistake there.
We went right.
We should have got left.
These ones, some of them
are going to be sketch bits.
Some of them are not.
But whichever ones
get underlined,
it's going to be a
1, which means we're
going to do the right thing.
We want the very rightmost
item in this tree.
So if we always go right
whenever there's a sketch bit,
and then do a search
in sketch space,
we will find the rightmost
item in this tree.
So if we then do a
search on e, we're
always going to get
the right answer.
So in the end, we're going do
two searches in sketch space,
once with q to find this
place where we fell off,
then once with e where we
actually find the right answer.
And there's a symmetric case,
which is if we went left and we
should have gone right,
then we go right,
and then we put a lot of 0's.
Because then we want to
find the min in that tree.
So, back to search, we
compute sketch of q.
We find it among the
sketch of the xi's.
This gives us this y.
So we find the
longest common prefix,
y equals longest common prefix
of q and xi or xi plus 1.
Then we compute e, and then we
find sketch of e among sketch
of xi's.
And the claim is that the
predecessor and successor
of sketch of e among sketch
of xi's equals the predecessor
and successor of q, our
actual query, among the xi's.
So this is a claim.
It needs proof.
But it's what I've been
arguing that e gives us
the right structure.
It fixes all the sketch bits
that are potentially wrong.
We found the first sketch
bit that was wrong.
We fixed that one.
And then the remainder, as
long as we go all the way
to the right, we'll find the
max, or in the other case
we want to go all
the way to the left
because we want to find the min.
So that's this claim.
We find the predecessor
of sketch of e.
Run the sketch of the xi's,
which is just this thing again.
So again, we can do
it in constant time.
Then we find--
I mean I have to be a little
bit more precise here.
Of course, we find the
predecessor and successor,
we get a sketch of the xi.
We have to undo that
sketch operation.
Really the way to think of it
is predecessor and successor
are really returning a rank.
I want to know the
i that matters.
So if it fits between sketch
of xi and sketch of xi plus 1,
if sketch of e
fits between those,
then I know that q will fit
between xi and xi plus 1,
in terms of that rank, i,
the index in the array.
So, that makes sense.
This is the end of the--
what's the right way to put it?
This is the big picture
of fusion trees.
At this point you should
believe that everything works.
And overall, what are we doing?
We're building a
w to the 1/5 tree.
It's not yet clear
why w to the 1/5.
And so we have to
implement these nodes that
only have w to the 1/5 keys.
So we're looking
at a single node.
And say, hey look,
there's a bunch of keys.
Let's just look at
the important bits.
That defines the
sketch operation.
Now if we want to do a search,
we do this double search.
We compute the sketch, find
the sketch among the sketches,
find our mistake,
compute our proper query,
compute the sketch of that, find
that sketch among the sketches,
and then that index in the array
of sketches will be the correct
index of our actual
query q among the xi's.
Now, there are
several things left
to be done in a reasonable way.
One is how do we
compute sketches.
How do we do this
kind of operation
of taking the bits we care
about and bringing them
all next to each other?
Second thing is, how
do we do this find?
This parallel comparison.
So it's basically all
the bullets up here.
We have how do we
do a sketch, how
do we do parallel comparison
to find where one sketch fits
among many sketches, and there's
also a most significant set
bit.
Where did we do that?
In computing the
longest common prefix.
So if you have two
bit strings and you
want to know where
did they first differ,
the natural way to
do that is compute
the XOR, which gives you
all the differing bits.
And then find the first
one bit from the left.
So this is really most
significant set bit.
So, we need that operation.
So, we have our
work cut out for us.
But the overall
picture of fusion trees
should now be clear.
It just remains to do
these three things.
And this is where the
engineering comes in,
I would say.
Any questions about
the big picture?
So, the first thing I'm
going to do is sketch.
And as I've hinted at
in the outline here,
we're not going to
do a perfect sketch.
We're going to do an
approximate sketch.
This will probably
be the most work
among any of these operations.
Parallel comparison is
actually quite easy.
Sketching is, I think,
the biggest insight
in Fusion trees.
So, perfect sketch
takes just the bits
you care about that we need.
We only want to look at
the bits we care about.
But it's easy to look at
We can apply a mask, and just
AND out the bits we care about.
Everything else we can zero out.
So that's easy.
The hard part is compression,
taking these four bits
and making them four
consecutive bits.
But they don't really
need to be consecutive.
If I added in some 0's here
in a consistent pattern
that would still work.
I'd still preserve the
order among the sketches.
And that's all I care about.
And this is where I'm going
to use the slop I have.
Because right now I
have w to the 1/5 keys.
If I did perfect sketch,
the total number of bits
would only be w to the 2/5.
But I can go up to w.
So what I'm going
to do is basically
spread out the bits,
the important bits,
in a predictable pattern
of length w to the 4/5.
Predictable just means it
doesn't depend on what x is.
So when there are extra 0's
here, you know that's fine.
But there's always going to
be two 0's here, one 0 here,
three 0's here, no
matter what x was.
As long as it's predictable,
I'm going to preserve order.
And as long as it's
length order w to the 4/5,
if I take w to the
1/5 of them, that
will still fit in a
constant number of words.
Because it will be
order w bits total.
So that's what I can afford.
And now I'm going to do it.
So here's how.
First thing, as I
said, is we're going
to mask the important bits.
I just want the important bits.
I should throw away
all the others.
And so this is going to be x
prime equals x bit-wise AND.
And here's where I'm going to
use the notation that the bits
count from the right.
I want the bi-th bit to
correspond to the value 2
to the bi.
This thing is just a bit string.
It has 1's wherever
the important bits are.
So if this is the
b0, b1, b2, and b3;
I just want this bit string.
I mean, you can think of this
as 1 shifted left bi times.
So I get 1's in exactly
the positions I care about.
And if I bit-wise AND
that with x it zeros out
all the other bits.
This is what we call masking.
So that's the
obvious thing to do.
And then the second
idea is multiplication.
And it's just like, well, maybe
we could do it with a multiply,
and then we'll just work it out.
And the answer is yes, you
can do it with a multiply.
So that I imagine
was the big insight
was to see that multiplication
is a very powerful operation.
So we're just going to do x
prime times some number m.
And we're going to prove
that there exists a number
m that does what we need.
So I'm going to write this out
a little bit algebraically.
So we can think about
what m might be.
Now x prime only has
the important bits.
So we can write that as a sum i
equals 0 to r minus 1 of xbi 2
to the bi.
So I am introducing
some notation here. xbi,
is that important bit bi 1 or 0?
This is just a de-reference of
the bit vector or a bit string.
And so you multiply
that by that position.
I mean this the definition
of binary notation, right?
But we only care about
the important bits.
Because only those are set.
So that's x prime.
And then we're
multiplying that by m.
Now m could have any bit set.
So I'm going to--
but I'm going to
write it like this.
I'm going to assume that
m only has r bits set,
same as the number
of important bits,
r is a number of important bits.
But I don't know where they are.
So I'm just going to suppose
they're at positions m0, m1,
up to mr minus 1.
I've got to find what these
mi's should be, or mj's.
And now just taking
this product,
so we can expand out the
product algebraically
and see what we get.
So, what's this product?
Sum i equals 0 to
r minus 1 sum j
equals 0 to r minus 1 of xbi--
I mean just the
product of these.
So 2 to the bi plus mj.
That's the algebraic
product of those two things.
That's why I wrote
it out this way.
So I can see what's going on.
The point is when you
do multiplication,
you're doing these
pairwise products.
Now the guys that
are going to survive
are the ones where the
xbi's are 1, of course.
But they survive
in multiple places.
Essentially the mj's
shift all of those bits
by various amounts.
So it used to be at this
position, 2 to the bi.
But now we're shifting
it by mj for all j.
So some of those bits
might hit each other.
Then they add up.
That's really messy.
We're going to avoid
that, and design
the mj's so that all of
these values are unique.
Therefore, bits
never hit each other.
That's step one.
And then furthermore, what we
care about or what we're trying
to do is to get the xbi's to
appear in a nice little window,
consecutive interval
of w to the 4/5 bits,
somehow by setting the mj's.
So let me tell you
the claim, which
we will prove by induction.
So we're given these bi's
that we can't control.
Those are the important bits.
And the claim is we can
choose the mi's such
that three properties hold.
First one is that bi plus mj
are distinct for all i and j.
So that was that these bits
don't collide with each other.
So there's no actual
summation here.
These sums could
then be replaced
by ORs, which makes
it very easy to keep
track of where the
bits are going, if we
can achieve this property.
Property b is that it
turns out that the bits
I'm going to end up
caring about our b0
plus m0, b1 plus m1,
and general bi plus mi.
In general, we have bi plus
mj for different values
of i and j.
I claim the ones I care
about are the ones where
i and j are equal.
So I'm going to
look at these bits,
and in particular I want
them to appear in order
in the bit string.
And then third property--
I need some more space--
is that if I look at
the span of those bits,
so I look at br minus
1 plus mr minus 1
minus b0 plus m0 that is the
interval that these bits span.
I want that to be order
r to the fourth power.
Because r was w to the 1/5.
So this would be
order w to the 4/5.
That's what I need for
everything to fit in.
So this is guaranteeing
that these bits
are the sketch that I need.
They appear in
order, and they don't
span a very large interval,
just w to the 4/5.
This is what I need to prove.
If I can prove this, I
have approximate sketching.
So let's prove it.
Proof happens in two steps.
First thing I'm
going to worry about
is just getting
these guys distinct.
Then I'll worry about
the order property.
So here's how we
get them distinct.
And these are going
to be the mi primes,
not quite the mi's that we want.
They're all going to be integers
less than r cubed, greater than
or equal to 0, and they're
going to have the property
that the bi's plus mj primes
are distinct mod r cubed.
So this is a stronger
version of a.
We really just need
them to be distinct.
But to make it easier
for the other steps,
we're going to force them
to be distinct mod r cubed.
How do we do this?
By induction.
So let's suppose that we've
picked m0 up to mt minus 1.
So suppose by induction
that we've done that.
And now our goal is
to pick mt prime.
So how do we choose mt prime?
Well, what can't it be?
mt prime has to avoid
basically mi prime,
and believe minus bj plus b--
we're going to call it k?
I guess so.
If it avoids all
expressions like this,
then mt prime plus bj
will be different from mi
prime plus bk.
In other words, all of these
things will be distinct.
So it has to avoid
this modulo r cubed.
If I can avoid all
of these things--
so this is for all ijk--
if I can choose mt prime
to avoid all those,
then I'm happy.
Because then these things
will continue to be distinct,
and then I apply induction.
Well, how many choices
are there for i, j, and k?
For i, there's I
guess t choices.
Because mi can be any
of the previous values.
For j, let's call it r choices
for k, there's r choices.
That's how many
important bits there are.
So total number of
choices is tr squared.
But t here is
always less than r.
So this is going to
be less than r cubed.
So that means there is
less than r cubed things
we have to avoid.
But I have r cubed
allowable choices
on working modulo r cubed.
So I just pick any one
that avoids the collision.
This is basically deterministic
hashing, in a certain sense.
We are choosing these
values deterministically
to avoid collisions in
this simple hash function.
OK.
It takes time.
It's going to take polynomial
time to compute this thing.
And you can imagine if
you just plug in hashing,
this will work with
some probability,
and blah, blah, blah.
But I want to make it always
work deterministically.
Because we know what
the xi's are here.
All right.
So we've avoided collisions.
There's enough space.
That's all.
That was step one.
Step two, and this
will solve property a,
even modulo r cubed.
Now we have a
little bit of space.
We're allowed to go
up to r to the fourth.
And now we just need to
spread out these bits.
So that's step two.
Basically we're going to set
mi to be these values that we
chose plus this weird thing,
w minus bi plus ir cubed
rounded down to a
multiple of r cubed.
So I guess you could put this
in parentheses if you want.
Rough idea is, we want to
take mi prime plus ir cubed.
Because these mi primes,
they're all values between 0,
and r cubed minus 1.
We got everything
working modulo r cubed.
If we could just add ir
cubed to each of these values
that we'll spread them out.
Because each of these
values used to fall just
in this tiny range ir cubed.
So we can move the next
one to the next position,
move the next one to the
next position, and so on.
Spread them out to
the left by adding
on multiples of r cubed, then
that will achieve property b.
The annoying issue here is
we don't want to mess things
up modulo r cubed.
So we need to round
things down to be
a multiple of r cubed so that
this is congruent to mi prime.
That's what we want.
We want it to stay
congruent to mod r cubed.
Well, why do we need to round
down to a multiple of r cubed?
We were adding on ir cubed.
Well, it's not quite
mi that we care about.
It's mi plus bi.
Those are the bits that we
want to be nicely ordered.
And so we kind of
need a minus bi here,
so that when we take mi
plus bi, those cancel.
But then bi is not a
multiple of r cubed.
So you've got to do this
rounding down to r cubed.
Also negative bi is
a negative number.
And we can't really deal
with negative numbers.
Because you can't go left of 0.
So we have to add on this w
just to make things work out.
So it's a little
messy, and I don't
want to spend too much time
on why this formula works.
But I think you have the
essence of what's working.
This is just to avoid
negative numbers.
This negative bi is so that when
you add it to mi that cancels.
And so you get these
r cubes separations.
In the end, let me draw
a picture, perhaps.
In the end, if you look at the
bit space, so this is w bits.
And you divide it up into
multiples of r cubed.
All of the mi primes
are over here.
So these are mi primes.
You don't know in what
order or anything.
They're just kind of randomly
in there, and chosen pretty much
arbitrarily on the low
end of the spectrum,
from 0 to r cubed minus 1.
And then what we want
is for x0 plus m0
to fall somewhere in this
range, and then x1 plus m1
range, and x2 plus m2
to fall somewhere in this range.
If I do that, and it's
weird because the bits
are numbered from
0 to the left here.
Then I will have this property.
I claim this
assignment does that.
It's an exercise you can check
that indeed xi plus mi will
fall in this range.
So this gives us property b.
It also gives us property c.
Because we've been
fairly tight here.
There's r of these guys, and
r of these intervals of size r
cubed.
And so the total
range of these bits
is going to be r to the fourth.
We started at x0 plus m0.
We end at xr minus
1, plus, mr minus 1.
That's going to
be somewhere here.
But if you look at just
that interval of bits--
so there are more bits actually
over here, in particular,
because of this w bit part.
This whole picture
basically starts at bit w.
Then there's all
this stuff to 0.
So this is a more
accurate picture.
You're doing this
multiplication.
Garbage happens here.
We have no idea.
Actually, garbage
happens all over here.
But what we know
is that these bits
are the bits we care about.
These are the xi plus mi bits.
If you look at xi plus
mi, they give you xbi.
They exist in other places.
But these bits will
have the important bits.
Now the bits are also
all over everywhere else.
But none of the
bits hit each other.
So these bits remain
correct, because nothing else
collides with it.
And so if I just mask
out those bits, again,
so I have to do another mask.
I did one mask here.
I did a multiplication, and
then I have to do another mask.
So why don't I
write it over here?
So we AND with sum i
equal 0 to r minus 1 of 2
to the bi plus mi.
Those are the circled bits.
So if we grab those things,
and then we shift right by--
why am I writing x?
Sorry.
These are all b's.
Too many letters.
We shift right by b0 plus m0.
Because we don't care about
all those leading bits.
So we shift this
over to the left.
We did the mask, then we will
just have the important bits
and they will occupy over here
an interval of size at most--
I'll say order r to the fourth.
Clear?
So this is
approximate sketching.
This is definitely a bit
complicated, but it works.
Let me review briefly.
So, our algorithm was simple.
We have a bit string, x.
We just want to get
the important bits
and compress them to a thing
of size r to the fourth.
So first of all, we threw away
all the non-important bits
with this mask.
That was easy.
Then we just did an
arbitrary multiplication,
and we proved that there
was a multiplication that
avoided collision.
So the sums basically
turned into ORs or XORs.
I mean you never get two
1 bits hitting each other,
so you don't have
to worry about that.
And we did that with the
simple inductive argument.
And then we also wanted
the bi's plus mi's
to be linearly ordered.
Because we need to preserve the
order of the important bits.
We can't just permute them.
And we needed them to
occupy a small range.
And we did that
basically by adding
ir cubed to each of them.
But it was a little messy
and we had to add w,
and blah-blah-blah.
But in the end, we
got our important bits
to be nicely spaced out
here by pretty much putting
an r cubed in between each one.
So those were our
bi plus mi bits.
They occupied this range
of r to the fourth.
We'll mask out all the
rest of the garbage.
Because this multiplication
made a quadratic number of bits.
We only want these r bits,
the r squared 1 bits in here.
We'll mask away all the others.
Take these bits,
shift them over.
Now they occupy a nice interval
at the beginning size order r
to the fourth.
And that's our
approximate sketch.
So sketch should only take
r, but we're being sloppy.
With this multiplication
trick, the best we know
is to get down to
r to the fourth.
And that's good enough.
And that's why I set everything
to w to the one fifth.
Because this is w to the 4/5.
We're going to have
w to the 1/5 of them.
And so if you take
these sketches
and you concatenate them, fuse
them together if you will,
and that's fusion trees.
Then the sketches of all of
the keys x0 up to xk minus 1
will occupy order 1 words.
Because it's order w bits, w
to the 4/5 times w to the 1/5.
Which brings us to
parallel comparison.
I have all of these
approximate sketches.
So you could start forgetting
approximate sketching.
Somehow, we get these
w to the 4/5 bits.
We want to concatenate them
together, and then in parallel
compare all of them
to the sketch of q.
The sketch of the xi's
we can preprocess.
We can actually
spend a lot of time
finding the sketch function.
But then we have to fix
the sketch function.
We have to be able to compute
a sketch of q in constant time.
That's what we just did.
Sketch of q is one AND one
multiplication and another AND.
So computing sketches is fast.
That's the steps of
computing sketch of q.
Now, next step is find it
among the sketch of the xi's.
So this is the next thing
we want to make fast.
It's actually pretty easy.
You probably know you
can compare two integers
by subtracting one
from the other.
So we're just going to do
that, but in a clever way,
so we can do k subtractions
for the price of one.
I'm going to define the sketch
of a node to be 1 bit followed
by the sketch of x0 dot, dot,
dot, 1 sketch of xk minus one.
And I'm going to define a
sketch of q to the k-th power,
so to speak, to be a 0 bit
followed by sketch of q, dot,
dot dot, zero bit sketch of q.
This is aligning
things, so that if I
did this subtraction
and this one,
I would basically be comparing
q with all the xi's at once.
The point is these sketches--
this is the thing that
fits in order 1 words.
These sketches are
w to the 4/5 bits,
and there's w to
the 1/5 of them.
So this whole thing
is order w bits.
So it fits in one word.
This thing also.
It happens to be the same
bits repeated many times
but also it fits in one word.
How do I compute this thing?
I can do it with multiplication.
It's sketch of q times
0000001, 000000001.
So, ahead of time, I'll just
pre-compute this bit string
that has 1's at the rightmost
slot for each of these k
fields.
If I just take that and
multiply it by sketch of q,
then I get this.
So this is easy to do
in one multiplication.
Now, I take this thing
minus this thing.
I take the difference.
And the key thing is because
I put these 1 bits here, I'm
taking this minus this.
The point is either this 1 bit
will get borrowed when I do
binary subtraction, or it won't.
It gets borrowed when
this is bigger than this,
otherwise it doesn't
get borrowed.
So I'm going to
get either a 0 or 1
here, and then
some garbage which
I don't care about, and a 0 or
a 1 here, and then some garbage.
And I'll just mask that out.
I'm ANDing with 10000, 100000.
And so I end up just with
01 bits and the rest 0's.
And these bits,
if I get it right,
it's 1 if the sketch
of q is less than
or equal to the sketch of xi.
And it's 0 if the sketch of q is
greater than the sketch of xi.
Because when it's greater
that's when the borrow happens.
And then the 1 turns into a 0.
So 1's indicate the query is
too small or they're just right.
And 0's indicate
that they're greater.
Now the xi's were in order.
So probably x0 is too small.
And so this bit will
end up being a 0.
Probably xk this
plus 1 is too big.
So this bit will be a 1.
In general, it's going to be
a monotone sequence of bits.
If you look at these
bits, these 01 bits,
they are going to be monotone.
They'll be 0 for a while,
and then at some point
they'll switch to being 1's.
And that transition from 0 to
1 that's what we want to find.
These keys are too small.
These keys are too big.
This key is just right.
So we fit between--
this would be position
i and position i plus 1.
And we fit between
xi and xi plus 1.
Well, not actually
We fit between sketch of
xi and sketch of xi plus 1.
That's what we need to find.
Now that is again the
problem of finding
the most significant 1 bit.
But in this case, I don't
need that operation.
I can do it in a simpler way.
But we're almost done, right?
We've done all of this
parallel comparison.
We just need to find that
transition between 0's and 1's.
Turns out there's a
cool way to do it.
The cool way is multiply that
word times our good friend,
this thing, 000001, 000001.
This is a little
harder to think about.
But take this bit string
and multiply it by this.
What that does is it
takes this string.
It includes it.
Because there's a 1 right there.
It shifts it over by one field,
and includes it, shifts it over
by another field, includes it.
So this repeats this thing.
And now collision happens,
because they're perfectly
aligned.
If these 1 bits ever hit each
other, they'll be summing.
Now, some of them are
0, some of them are 1.
Instead of computing
the position of the 0
to 1 transition, we could
equivalently just count
how many 1's are there.
I mean that's counting
from the right,
whereas this is counting of from
the left, whatever, same thing.
So if I could count how
many 1's I'd be all set.
And in this case, if
you look at right here,
this will be the
number of 1's I claim.
Because if this one was
there, it will stay there.
And then all the other bits
get shifted over and fall
right here on top of this bit.
So as they get added up,
you'll get some carries
and things will move over.
But this is not very big.
Because we're
talking about k bits.
So this is only going
to be with log k.
I mean there's tons
of room here before we
get to the next shift.
So I just look at these bits.
I mask them out.
I shift them over.
And that gives me
the number of 1's.
This is a cute way to count the
number of ones in a bit string
when the bits are
spread out nicely.
They have to be at least
log k away from each other.
Otherwise you get collision.
It doesn't work for an
arbitrary bit string.
But for a bit string
like this, we're all set.
We can count how
many 1's there are.
Then we figure out where
this transition is.
That is parallel comparison.
One more thing to do, which
is most significant set bit.
The place we needed this, was
we were taking the XOR of q
with xi.
And then we wanted
to find the first bit
where they were differing.
So after you take
the XOR, you've
got some bit string
that looks like this.
And you want to find
this bit, because that's
the place you diverged.
Then we would turn that to 0
and change the rest to 1's.
That's easy to do if we
know where this bit is.
And this is a generally
useful operation.
It's used all over computer
science, I would say.
So much so that most CPUs
have it as an instruction,
so on Intel it's called CLZ.
And it has many names.
They're in the notes.
Most compilers
provide this to you
as an operation on
architectures that have it,
otherwise they simulate it.
They probably don't
simulate it as well
as I'm going to tell you.
Because we're going to
do this in constant time
on a regular word RAM,
just C operations,
which does not seem to have
made it into popular culture.
It's slightly
complicated, which is why.
But what's cool is
we're going to use--
I'm going to do this
relatively quickly.
Because I don't
have a ton of time.
We're going to use all the
things that we just did again,
quickly.
Most of them just
as black boxes.
All right.
So, here's what
we're going to do.
Maybe I should go somewhere new.
So, I'm going to use sketches,
not approximate sketches,
but I'm going to sketches.
I'm going to use multiplication.
I'm going to use
parallel comparison.
And in some sense I'm going to
use most significant set bit.
All of these things
I'm going to use
to solve the most
significant set bit problem.
So here's what we do.
We split the word into root
w clusters of root w bits.
Sound familiar?
This is exactly what we
did in van Emde Boas.
So van Emde Boas did
this recursively.
We're going to do it once.
We can only afford
constant time.
So here's an example.
x is 0101, 0000, 1000, 1101.
So each of these is root w bits.
There's root w of them.
It's approximate.
It doesn't it to be exactly.
But we'll assume x is
a nice power of two,
so that works cleanly.
So the first thing, so what
the high level idea is I
need to find the first
non-empty cluster.
Here it happens to
be the first cluster.
And then I need to find the
first 1 bit within the cluster.
Hard part is finding the
first non-empty cluster.
Actually, the hard
part or the messy part
is finding which
clusters are empty
and which clusters are not.
This cluster is not empty.
This cluster is empty.
These are non-empty.
So I want the summary
vector which is 1011.
I claim if I can do that,
everything else is easy.
So let's spend some time on
identifying non-empty clusters.
First thing I do is I take x,
ANDed with this thing, which
I'm going to call F, 1000,
1000, 1000, 1000; F for first.
So I'm just seeing which
of these first bits
in each cluster are set.
So the result is I get
0000, 0000, 1000, and 1000.
So in particular that tells me
this cluster and this cluster
are non-empty, because they
have the first bit set.
What about all those other bits?
Well, the other bits I'm going
to do in a different way.
Just the first bits, I
need a little bit of room.
I need this bit of room.
I want to put these 1's in.
So I've got to get rid of some
bits to make room for that.
So this deals with
the first bits.
Now I'm going to
clear those out.
So I'm going to take x XOR this.
And that will give me everything
with the first bits cleared.
So I've got 0101,
0000, 0000, and 0101.
These are the rest of the
bits I've got to figure out.
This one is non-empty
and this one's non-empty.
How do you do it?
With subtraction.
I take F minus that thing.
This F has 1's, and they're
going to get borrowed.
When I take F minus this,
this 1 will get borrowed
because there's something here.
This one will not get
borrowed because this is 0.
This one will get borrowed
because there's something here.
That's it.
We're comparing
with 0 everything.
So we're going to get, in
this case, 0 and some garbage,
1 and 0's, 1, and 0
with some garbage.
I just care about these bits.
These are the bits that tell
me which ones were empty.
The 0's are empty.
The 1's are non-empty.
So I do a mask.
I get 0, and some 0's, 1 and
some 0's, 1 and some 0's 0
and some 0's.
OK.
Then I do an XOR with F. Because
I really want 1 for these guys,
and 0 for these guys.
1 means it's not empty.
0 means it's empty.
I got that right.
So I'm just inverting the 0
bits to 1 bits, and vice versa.
So 1 means this one's not empty.
1 means this one's not empty.
Those are the non-empty guys.
I take this and I OR
it with this thing.
This was the thing
that told me which
ones had that first bit set.
So if I take the OR of those
two I learn, or any bit set.
Because this was dealing
with all of the other bits.
I threw away this bit,
but I had to remember
that it was non-empty.
OK.
So I take that OR.
Now, this tells me those
three blocks were not empty.
This one was empty.
So now here I have the
bits that I care about.
Sadly they're spread out.
I'd really like them compressed.
So I do that with sketch.
I want to compress them to 1011.
It would fit in one
little thing here.
Because this is root w.
There's root w of them.
Sadly, I can't use
approximate sketch.
Because I don't
have enough space.
This is w to the 1/2.
If I used approximate
sketch I get w--
I'd lose this factor of
4 and be bigger than w.
I really need it to
be perfectly sketched.
Conveniently, you can do
perfect sketch in this regime.
Before the bi's were
arbitrary things.
We had no idea how
they were spread out.
Here bi is root w minus
1-- that's the first one--
plus i times root w.
They're nicely uniformly
spaced by i root w.
In this case--
I'm running out of time--
I claim you can use mj equal to
w minus root w minus 1 minus j
root w plus j.
And I won't go to the proof.
There's a sketch in the notes.
If you do this, this is
a nice setting of mj.
It turns out you will get bi--
if we look at bi plus mi,
this cancels, this cancels,
because i equals j.
You're left with w plus j.
So in other words, if
you look at bi plus mi,
you get from bit w to bit
w plus root w minus 1.
These bits will be exactly
the bits you care about.
So you take those.
You mask out the others.
You shift it over to
the right, and you have
exactly your perfect sketch.
The thing you need to prove
here is that bi plus mj are all
distinct.
So there's no collisions.
But in this case it's
easy to avoid collisions.
You've got all your bits
nice and consecutive.
Now you've got it
down to this thing.
OK, not quite done though.
Only one more minute.
Let's say-- well,
that was step one.
Identify non-empty clusters.
Step two was sketch.
Step three is find the
first non-empty cluster.
I claim this is easy.
So I take this sketch vector.
It only has root w bits.
So I use parallel comparison.
What do I compare to?
I'm going to compare many copies
of this thing to 0001, 0010,
0100, 1000; the powers of 2.
So I take this.
I put them in a vector
like the sketch of a node.
And I take the k, or I guess
root w copies of the sketch
of the summary vector.
That's this 1011.
So I compare four copies
of this to each of these,
and I learn which power
of 2 it is greater than.
In other words, what is the
most significant set bit.
That's why when I told you
how to do over here, when
I told you how to do
parallel comparison,
I didn't want to use
most significant bit
as a subroutine.
Because this is a subroutine
to most significant bit.
Over here, we could just do
this multiplication and boom,
we found what the
most significant set
bit was as long as
there was room to fit
all this stuff in a word.
And because I've reduced
everything to size root w,
and then only there's
w of these things
to compare to, because
that's the width of one
of these fields.
This all fits in a word.
I can do this
parallel comparison.
Boom, I find the first 1 bit
in this bit string, which
happens to be the first bit.
That tells me that this cluster
is a cluster I care about.
So I take those bits out.
I mask them out,
shift them over,
and I find the first
1 bit in that cluster.
How do I do it?
In exactly the same way,
clusters again, root w bits.
I can use parallel
comparison to compare it
to all these things
in constant time.
I find where the
first 1 bit is there.
And then I take this cluster
C, I take this bit D,
and my answer is
C root w plus D.
That is the final index of
the most significant 1 bit
in constant time, using all
those fusion tricks once again.
And that in the end
gives you fusion trees
on a word RAM static.
It's complicated, probably
impractical, but pretty cool.
And we're going to use
these bit tricks again.